she got the lucky one sure go home get
lucky
hi nice to meet you my name is lily yen
and i am from taiwan so i'm gonna show
you how to make chinese dumpling taiwan
styles okay let's get started so usually
i may need with the soy sauce and not
much because we got put some salt so you
don't want too much soy sauce add some
white pepper and then put a little bit
of ginger in there ginger is good for
the body when you have a cold that's my
grandmother we say take away your cold
so then you want to sit this aside for
10 15 minutes and then you want to drop
your green chopped vegetables about two
thirds of the meat and once the
vegetable and then just kind of mix
together first time i see anyone using
bok choy in the dumpling for the first
time for me too
but i never never seen anybody do that i
usually don't use the chinese cabbage
because it's too much water you blow the
dumpling skin and then i put some wine
in there just to make it taste good so
what you do is because this is a machine
make skin so you need to use water to
dip on the side so you will stick it
together so when we're a kid they can
wrap all kinds of shapes but my
grandmother always makes like chinese
money it's nice right the way she's
folding it's so cute yeah and then you
put the almond in the center you can
hide it
this is like secret ingredient you don't
want to tell anybody so the lucky person
they're just going to have the almond in
the center and when they bite the exact
crunchy i wish my husband would do that
and put a diamond ring in it oh my gosh
so i'm ready to put in the boiled water
you can just slowly put it in there okay
and then you want to make sure you stir
a little bit you don't want to then
stuck in the bottom and then i just pour
another cup of water and then i just put
the cover when the dumpling is ready
they will flow on top and meanwhile i
can just mix the sauce soy sauce and
then i have a little sesame oil put a
little wine there just for the taste
some people like a lot of wine so they
can get a little buzz okay and then i
have to put little shop in there and
then garlic
and ginger and then i usually put a
little jalapeno actually this is not
chinese just for the test that's your
dipping sauce so they all blow up like
this okay when i could look like a
little bubble so meanwhile i just put
some oh yeah because if you don't finish
it right away they stick it together the
thing about my shape it can even stand
up look at that
[Music]
my name is jiao julio i came from
mainland of china because shenyang is
northeast first of all i'm gonna soak a
spice got rid of the fishy smile from
the meat spice green onion and ginger
and i'm gonna put hot water inside any
grandma make dumpling can make a pork
dumpling but lamb is difficult you got
to cook perfect otherwise it doesn't
taste good honestly i only know how to
use pork i don't even know how to use
chicken next i've been making a dough
only flour and with warm water you know
people can use the hot water cold water
we prefer the warm water that way the
dough is soft it's not too soft and not
too hard it's perfect condition i think
okay now so far now i like to let it
sleep like 20 minutes but normally like
two hours three hours it's better cover
it tight don't let moisture go up so
much mess what the heck if you walk all
day and i come home to this get it
modern time you just use the
store-bought wrapper okay next step i'm
gonna put the cooking wine into the meat
soy sauce this is my special one low
salty but more tasty look good too a
little bit salt
this is called massage the lamb next
step make this is spicy water so this
water can kill the fishy smell i call
the fishy smell now it's the fun part
you you know you got to do the clockwise
or counter clockwise one direction you
don't mix it you don't like to this one
this one you don't know that then when i
was kid i see my mom do this all the
time and i try to help i try to do the
different way my mom said no no you
cannot do that so why you mess up the
lamb i said why no not tasty why and
don't ask me why too many questions just
not good okay i said okay i just watch
and eat this is the exercise too work
out you know
did you see the perfect time not too
much watery and not dry that's the
perfect now i'm mix the onion i like red
onion better white onion is a little
sweet but right on it it's spicy that's
a lot of onion and it has a lot of water
too and then she already dumped the
water
and the cucumber cucumber makes the
dumpling like a fresh smell sesame oil a
little bit this is olive oil they can
lock the water of the vegetables inside
that's all for the meat now i'm taking
out of the top to make the skin
oh very good gotta use
one thumb into
fresh and one hand
you know roll it like this after you do
the doubling your thumb you know
you'll be sore
then you make a hole inside and just do
like this
[Music]
i see a lot of people call it little
pieces i prefer like use my hand like a
piece of art it's fun i enjoy it
now i put a little dry flower on the top
so when you make the skin it doesn't
stick on the board
i use the stick to make the skin she
does it so
professionally wow looks so thin too
see the way you got the roll they sew
very fast otherwise too much here and
two last there the center is a little
hard you don't go all the syrup
otherwise the dumpling will burst
finished
filling in when i was kidding i told you
my grandma made the thumbnail like this
i said my grandma look like let's look
like a bug i don't want to eat it she
said you got to eat it after i cook it
you'll feel the butter delicious look
pretty or not now it's the steamed
dumpling time
okay that's enough
put on the top we will count 30 minutes
in the meantime i can make
garlic sauce first of all put the garlic
and then soy sauce
okay and then sesame oil let me mix it
okay let's check out the product
who won't try it
[Music]
hi my name is susanna tan and i'm from
hong kong today i'll be making truffle
dumplings do you know how to spell
travel it's kind of expensive no okay
first of all i have half a pound of pork
here and i have a piece of ginger and
i'm going to add some water to it so i
let this sit
while i put the rest of the ingredients
in it so i have a teaspoon of oyster
sauce a teaspoon of soya sauce and a
pinch of pepper and then i will add some
truffle salt what is that okay
truffle pate you can add as much as you
can honestly and the truffle oil i'm
going to strain the ginger water
and now i'm going to mix it all together
i just loosen it up in the liquid until
i get the consistency that i want i do
not need it because personally if i need
it i find that feeling becomes very
thick and hard after you cook them and
now i will just add the chives i do not
use a lot of chives because chives has
its distinctive taste to it and because
this is a truffle dumpling you do not
want the chives to cover the taste of
the truffle
voila so now i'm going to wrap it i
cannot fold it like how other people can
really fast i am pretty slow in doing
this but patient pays worth the weight i
like to make eight folds on my dumpling
because eight is very auspicious for the
chinese eight means prosperity and when
you make the dumplings it's supposed to
be in the shape of a chinese golden
nugget just like this like a half moon
so that's how it is i'm all ready to fry
them i'll add a little oil just a little
bit first it's not hot
yet so you can just swirl it around so
that the bottom has a bit of oil arrange
it nicely but make sure that it's not
touching each other okay now that it's a
little bit sizzling not a lot
i can add the water to it around the
side you can hear it sizzles a little
bit and i'm going to cover it with the
water like steaming half steaming half
boiling fry is most delicious but fry
you got to have a very good skill okay
now that you see the water has
evaporated a lot you can add the oil so
that we're gonna fry the bottom of it so
it becomes crispy
okay sounds very good it looks pretty
much done let's see how crisp it looks
it's golden brown
it smells good it's gotta taste good and
that's it
here it is
[Music]
oh so good girl so juicy can you try
yours yes of course please please please
please well you use very expensive oil
okay i'll try your spin
first time i have lamb in your whole
life in my whole life i'm surprised
it is so good and why why your girls
don't make the dough
okay honestly i don't know how to make
dough
how about you i know how to do it you
just don't want to do it yeah because
it's too much work
it's nice and lazy girl the dough tastes
good if you made your own right yeah
different taste yeah it tastes different
it's not only the lamb i think it's the
soul my soul
oh
[Music]
she had dancing down playing what is
that crunchy thing in it you got it
you're the lucky one
thanks for watching
[Music]
you